people forget how terrible they were at
one point don't judge the person by the
final product judge the person based on
who they used to be asked the questions
of who they used to be versus who they
are today many times we look at somebody
and they say man this guy's winning
because he is this this this this this
and I'm not gonna win because I don't
have this dis dis dis dis no you don't
need to look at that you need to look at
the person why they're winning and what
are some reasons that you can win and at
the end of the day unfortunately most
people believe the wrong lies so we have
two lies to believe one of the lies is
I'm a loser I'm not meant to do anything
big my dad was right I'm never gonna
amount to anything or we can buy the
other lie which is what one day I might
be a deca millionaire one day I'm gonna
be somebody that the world's gonna know
but I'm gonna make a big impact my live
in a big house both of them are lies
both of them are lies but it's on us to
make one of them the truth so if we
don't do anything when we die the truth
is we were losers or we can live a life
and give everything we got and then we
make this other lie the truth and we die
the truth is we were successful but we
have a choice which lie to believe if
you can choose between the two lies by
the right lies is what I suggest
you